puisque vous parlez de nicolas dupont
aignan vous avez passé un accord avec
l'ue en 2010 est est ce que vous
pourriez passer un tel accord avec eric
zemmour et nous verrons bien nous
verrons bien quelles sont ses
propositions aujourd'hui on ne les
connaît pas exclu mais marine le pen a
dit qu'il tendrait la main à tous les
patriotes qu'elle est ce qu'elle ferait
un gouvernement d'union nationale tous
ceux qui voudront travailler avec nous
dans la droite file du programme qui
aura fait élire marine le pen nous
travaillons avec eux bien évidemment 600
stylistes vous avez proposé à nicolette
du point de vue va être le premier
ministre de marine le pen vous pourriez
en faire de même avec écoute il faudrait
le demander à la candidate marine le pen
il devrait encore entendre parole merci
mais je ne connais pas aujourd'hui son
programme donc c'est un peu compliqué de
vous le dire je sais simplement qu'il a
fait un certain nombre de constats que
nous partageons il le fait parfois de
manière un peu brutale un peu radical
qui ne correspond pas à notre vision
d'une nation apaisée donc il y a du
travail à faire mais évidemment nous
avons comme on dit à l'école un tronc
commun et donc ça permet de travailler
ensemble éventuellement merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]